also tonight we're now officially on day
three of congressman eric swalwell
dodging questions about whether or not
he had
some type of romantic sexual
relationship with the chinese spy
a new bombshell axios report
a so-called quote they call it honey
trap working as an asset
but the communist chinese named
christina fang
had years-long relationship with
swalwell she bundled donations for him
even placed an intern in his
congressional office
2015 swalwall apparently because he's a
democrat cut ties with christina fang
after the fbi
uh provided him with a defensive
briefing about
this quote honey trap who is accused of
pursuing sexual relations with multiple
politicians
rick grinnell telling us last night that
it's much deeper than any of us even
know
now for four long years swalwall has
been one of the biggest
russia collusion hoaxers in the entire
country
and truthers and over and over again
he's accused the president of being
compromised by russia russia russia
and he lied lied lied just like the
corrupt congenital liar
adam schiff and even launched accusation
at members of the president's family
you might remember eric take a look
stated plainly the president's son met
with
a russian spy we now have the best
evidence of that
in our minority report the democrats put
out that ms veselnitskaya
was going all over the world now we know
that she was working at the behest
of the russian government the
president's son nicole met with a
russian spy
well you might have been dating a
chinese spy how about answering some
questions anyway
turns out he may have might have even
had sexual relationships with a
chinese spy so what does that make you
eric
an unwitting or winning asset of the
communist
chinese oh now you're all of a sudden
for the first time in your adult life
you're going to be quiet
very serious matter and swalwell serves
on the powerful house
intel committee that's where members
have access yep to america's most
classified secrets
if there was pillow talk that's a
problem and as minority leader kevin
mccarthy points out this is a
big problem democrats to try to sweep it
under the rug with a massive double
standard take a look
this is a national security threat that
the intel committee does not meet in
normal chambers they meet in what is
called a skiff
to protect from people listening in on
what they're talking about
they're getting secrets that other
members of congress
never are able to see when did nancy
pelosi know of this
and why did he he made why did she
maintain him on the committee
adam schiff who spent four years as
chair worried about the
foreign intervention into our country
knowingly keep an individual on the
committee
if he knew as suawell says that he was
with
a chinese individual who was a spy
now we did reach out to the corrupt
congenital liar compromise one adam
schiff for comment
as you can imagine we didn't get a
response he doesn't really like us
and of course schiff we know remember
all the talk about russia
he's the one guy that got caught on tape
thinking he's talking to a russian
and conspiring to get information to use
in a campaign remember that whole phone
call about
oh we got compromising materials on
donald trump what's the nature of the
compromise uh pictures of naked trump
does vladimir know about the whole thing
well there's no evidence that a foreign
spy has been willing to
get in bed with mr schiff he was caught
uh yeah on tape getting well kind of
played by
a hoaxter uh posing as a russian asset
saying they had pictures of naked trump
you know compromising materials
well anyway in other words caught on
tape colluding
another way to put it tonight the
swalwell scandal continues to unfold
several main questions remain do you
trust the judgment of a guy who had a
years-long relationship with the chinese
spy
and why the hell is he anywhere near the
house intelligence
committee and according to the daily
caller swallow actually spoke at a 2013
event
that also featured the chinese spy who
once worked in the office of
senator feinstein well the event was put
together by you guessed it
christina fang the girl that he might
have been dating
the spy he might have dated the spy who
may have loved him
here with reaction house minority leader
kevin mccarthy
you know i mean i can joke a little bit
about it but there's nothing funny this
guy's on the house intel committee
they have access to top secrets i'm not
even sure if you
get briefed on a lot of this stuff well
i'm one of the gang of eight i do
remember what the intel committee does
it not only keeps it seized america
secrets this is swalwell who's been
conned by the communist
he was compromised but what's worse is
speaker pelosi has covered for him
this goes much deeper than just swalwell
you when you
think about it if the speaker nancy
pelosi
and adam schiff knew this and kept him
on the committee
that raises a very big question it also
raises a question when the democrats
backed out of the bipartisan china task
force now it raises questions why would
they do that
what's most interesting is the chinese
has really focused on northern
california silicon valley
dianne feinstein for two decades her
body person the person driving hearing
all of her phone calls
a communist spy this wasn't that
swalwell went to the fbi
the fbi went to him knowing that because
they picked up
on this chinese spy following her and
the speaker knew about it
and adam's shift it raises more
questions
now when we we come into the new
congress in january third
the democrats don't just vote for who's
going to become speaker
if you vote for nancy pelosi you're now
voting to put adam schiff
back on the intel and swalwell and now
you know this information too
so you better watch how you vote well
let me ask you about comments going back
to the election and 106 members now
supporting this lawsuit by the texas
attorney general
and more importantly of all the 27
toss-up races
your side won 27 of them now they've
been big problems in the state of new
york
this week alone we got another what you
know last week 55 ballots now it's what
another 40 ballots
there's a 12 a 12 vote advantage for the
republicans claudia attending
between district 19 and district 22 a
lot of crap is going on in new york
and they're still finding ballots five
weeks later
yeah you know what we found out we're
ahead by 12 votes then they just came
forward and said oh we just found 12
ballots in this drawer what is going on
with new york 12. where have they been
for five weeks you just find ballots you
open up
you're gonna make coffee oh i found some
ballots here sorry i gotta hand them in
the myth the biggest mismanagement of
any state
is new york they put ballots out to
everybody
meaning when they have a role people are
dead people haven't lived there before
but this is what cuomo wanted to do
sinning to everybody
and now we had claudia tinney ahead by
tens of thousands of votes
now you're down to 12 and how many more
drawers are going to be open
every time they see the republican in
the lead okay
so do you think you're going to hold
that seat and is there anything the
republicans can do
to stop these states can we get real
one standard of signature verification
in georgia can in the state of
pennsylvania
can we stop the democrats from
making new laws while the election is
going on
or the legislature passing things that
are unconstitutional based on their
state constitution
or if they don't allow absentee i'm
sorry early voting in wisconsin
can we insist that they not hand out two
hundred thousand ballots like they did
i watch what they did in california as
well election all really goes by state
this is where we have to mobilize and
get involved within the state
never allowing this to move forward
again what we found though as you were
correct
we did not lose one incumbent how is in
congress
that when they predicted that we were
going to lose 15 to 20 seats
then now we're sitting at 212 maybe 213
five seats away from the majority the
senate was supposed to lose schumer
saying it
no we did not lose the senate and we're
going to win georgia the state
legislatures were supposed to lose no we
actually picked up three
and now they're saying we lost the
presidency these are the questions of
why
every legal do you believe it because i
don't believe it i think the
83 percent of gallup and the 77 percent
of quinnipiac
i think it stinks to high heaven and
everybody can see it now
every single poll was wrong but what we
found is you trust the american public
look at what this republican party did
inside the house nancy pelosi was
literally
days before saying she's going to win 15
seats she's holding on by a thread
and remember when you come to vote on
opening day
you have to be there and nancy pelosi
had 15 democrats vote against her last
time
10 of them are coming back if all 10
vote against her she will not be speaker
okay that will be interesting and by the
way
the supreme court needs to stand on the
law and the constitution
and these states they've made their mess
make them go back and fix it that's what
should happen
all right thank you sir